Crippled religions,
that's the right way to think about
them.
They're like a religion that's missing
an arm and a leg but can still haul bill
along and it,
it provides a certain amount of security
and group identity,
but it's,
it's warped and twisted and demented and
banter and it's a parasite on something
underlying that's rich and true.
And that's how it looks to me anyways.
And,
and so.
So I think it's very important that we
sort out this problem.
Um,
I think that,
I think that there isn't anything more
important that needs to be done than
that.
I've,
I've thought that for a long,
long time,
probably since the early eighties when I
started looking at the site,
the role that belief systems played in
regulating psychological and social
health,
um,
because they,
you can tell that they do that because
of how upset people get.
If you challenge their belief systems,
it's like,
why the hell do they care?
Exactly.
What difference does it make if,
if all of your ideological axioms are
100 percent correct?
Like people get unbelievably upset when
you,
when you poke them in the axioms.
So to speak,
and it isn't,
it is not by any stretch of the
imagination,
obvious why,
you know,
but there's some,
it's like there's a fundamental truth
that they're standing on.
It's like they're on a raft in the
middle of the ocean and you're starting
to pull up the logs,
you know,
and they're afraid they're going to fall
in and drown.
It's like drowning.
What and what are the logs protecting
themselves,
protecting them from and why are they so
afraid to,
to move beyond the confines of the
ideological system.
And these are not obvious things.